what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome
Melanie k
welcome Maggie the substitute
and some criticism from time to time
saying that Pearl doesn't have enough
life experience I'm not gonna name names
I will not do that but but what I did
decide to do was you know what let's
bring some women with life experience on
the channel to give their take on Modern
dating and relationships and if they
think that this um couple Dynamic is a
good idea and what they think so today
we are going to be reacting to I'm 24
and my husband is 69. so um before we
start why don't you guys plug in your
social media okay so you guys can follow
me on YouTube Melanie King and then also
on Instagram and uh also Tick Tock at
Mel underscore EA underscore hi
everybody I'm Maggie The Substitute
Teacher on teachable moments with Maggie
on YouTube so um what do you guys think
of the title what are you were you guys
in age Gap relationships ever yes not
that not that Gap well how old is she
again
um 24 he's 16.
um not that not that big of a gap but I
yeah I was previously married and my
ex-husband was 16 years older than me
and I've dated a guy that was 20 years
older than me that was probably my
second longest relationship when I was
younger oh wow my ex-husband was seven
years older than I don't think that
qualifies as an app but it was how how
big of an age Gap if you if you you do
have daughters
you have boys but but how big of an age
Gap oh you know what I'm gonna I wanna
know from both points of view is too
much of an age gap for your sons dating
younger and for your daughters dating
older I think past 20 years would be too
much in my opinion especially it depends
on her age her maturity I would say 20 I
mean 20 25 it just depends though like
if the guy is really you know a great
man he can provide and take care of her
I would say 20 25 years is probably the
most I could be okay with okay what
about you interesting I'm thinking about
15 and with boys it's a little different
because there's a win window where boys
have to be very careful once they turn
18 20 they have to make sure that
they're dating closer to their age range
but I've told both of the boys I think
30 is when you settle down so at that
point I would say it's a 15 year old at
30. exactly right 10 to 15. that's like
the way boys are mid-30s then they could
get away with 2021 yeah okay play that
play the clip blessing I think a lot of
people don't understand that age cap
relationships can be genuine I love you
the majority seem to assume that there's
got to be something else going on you
love somebody because you love them
[Music]
exchange right you might yeah if I do
like we were talking about yeah I'm Don
walper age 69. and I'm Stephanie wolper
and I'm 24. hold the door for you
[Music]
we've been together for just over four
years married since August and there's
45 years between us 45 good years yeah
were they good years
I don't know I wasn't there
that's great you want
you know Guinness
cheers Missy cheers baby it's like a
throwback family reunion before I met
Dawn I was living on my own I kept
getting a job quitting jobs finally I
settled on a job at a pub and I met you
Dawn used to come in when he was off
work every day pretty much every day and
have beers and relax and whatever
Stephanie appeared one day when I was
there I think most of the guys probably
oh got a new girl today hmm so we
started getting curious and talking and
flirting and different things like that
and it just kind of steadily progressed
we sat over here we were on the dance
floor like we were everywhere we partied
down until 2 30 in the morning and then
he stayed the night at my house then we
got in a cab and went to her house what
do you got what do you guys think you
know I I won't have an opinion because
of my age
I'll let Maggie go you know oh my
goodness I'm struggling so my initial
reaction I understand why men prefer
younger women however for me 45 is a bit
too far if I had to put parameters
around it I think like you said Melanie
like 20 years 15 to 20 years is probably
the max once you could be like fatherly
age for me personally that's that's a
little bit of a struggle and I noticed
there was a baby in there I don't know
if it's their baby but the other thing
that I have that's weird is if the man
has children that are the same age as
the wife that's a little bit weird so I
mean this isn't fatherly this is
Grandfather
let's keep it a buck I mean I just I
just find there are older men who are
very attractive Sean Connery was one man
that was oh girl I don't care if he was
a thousand okay but this man is not
attractive in any way to me I'm seeing a
lot of wrinkly hands and and liver spots
and problems I'm not changing your
diaper boo
um like if that is their child I believe
and I'm just thinking to myself like why
is he having eventually he like he's in
a stage where he could go with any I
mean he's not so old that he can go
anywhere but he could and then she now
won't have a husband the he's not going
to live to see this child grow up most
likely
um and a girl like that doesn't realize
you you're dealing with once he gets
into health problems like I said he may
need uh care you know dementia there's a
lot of things and I'm sorry I wouldn't
even date a man this age and I'm 41. I'm
sorry this is enough it just makes it
makes gross it makes you know I really
hate it when women use shaming tactics
so you know shame men for liking younger
women but I'm about to do it so
this just makes my stomach feel gross
um you know as a woman I got a lot of
feelings and this one is making me feel
grossed out and it's like how does your
life look because 20 years you know you
can if you meet a guy at 25 you still
have 20 30 40 years of good like life
with him but it's like a 45 year old it
can still you know what I'm saying it's
20 years 70. this man is not sexy in any
capacity he looks like something is
wrong like I don't know something's
wrong with her I'm sorry I think some I
think she actually probably has some
type of mental I'm just sorry he's just
not sexy like how do you even did y'all
see his arm well I I didn't see his arm
but what caught me is did you hear in
the beginning when she said she either
moved around a lot or changed jobs a lot
so she is not weird she's not stable
right in the head that's why I said
exactly so we're not talking about two
people that are settled and stabled and
for whatever reason their paths cross
and they met at a pub where she was
working at after having lot left several
jobs so I won't say the bottom of the
barrel but I will say that they aren't
um they're not the example that I would
I will say something I noticed so you
see Melanie's Nails
you see these are these are fake right
no no this is um these are my nails I
just have um
this is your real name
well okay they're an enamel so this is
what I was gonna say if you're gonna do
fake nails there's a classy way to do it
right and you get them like not to I
thought these are just so long I thought
they were fake but you know you you get
the a nice nude color and it's classy
but I just noticed her nails it's like a
bright color they're kind of long it's
just like oh they were I didn't even
yeah yeah so that was the first thing
that I noticed and can I be honest I
don't think it was a pub what it's
giving me when you just mentioned the
nail is that she was a stripper and he
used to come in as a as a customer
there's a calling it a pub but to me
it's giving stripper and sugar daddy and
she needed stability I bet that's the
truth girl there's so many places you
could go for stability there's so many
places you could go but I'm a mama I
mean like you could get it there's like
like 50 45 like yeah and did you hear
that was it his friends that said oh you
got a new girl which says something
about him this dude is nasty look at
that face bro I can't do it it is creepy
did he take his teeth out doesn't look
his teeth are gone I can't do it I'm
sorry I was surprised
I personally don't have a problem with
it but people giving them looks
[Music]
the best thing for me it's
been crazy crazy
it's giving Viagra nothing wrong with it
it's giving that oh no no
no no it's giving my guts hurt right now
I thought she was gonna say
companionship you know
um love oh my god well they did that
first night so he must have I wouldn't
let this man touch me through a glass
wall well I've heard you can still
perform well into yourself care about
performing you see his skin I can't do
it with the skin set and I mean it would
be a 20-year age gap for you or no 30
30.
unless he's looking unless he's looking
like Sean Connery now I'm saying Denzel
but I ain't gonna disrespect his wife I
can work with Denzel Denzel is is in in
his 70s like or 70 now so I can see
working with that you know what I'm
saying but not this no ma'am no man like
yeah okay okay yeah I could see I could
see dens I can see uh how old is um
Washington yeah no it's another guy
that's really looking good and he's
older I can't remember his name but what
if his benefits package because I've
heard you Melanie say a lot about how he
looks but as women what I thought women
who date older they like the
um the resources that a man has that has
made himself so what if he had what
resources he looked look at his house
look at his ride like I mean she must
come from literally the trash can if she
thinks that this is a benefits package
maybe I'm stuck up maybe I'm I'm just
too high sedidity but what benefits is
he providing me that's my benefit that
house I come home and I'm walking into
that no ma'am no ma'am keep those boxes
5am of the afternoon
before dinner after dinner in the middle
of dinner up on the rooftop on the
rooftop
on the balcony on the floor wherever
right
[Music]
it doesn't last two seconds he knows
what he's doing it's always different
we've done a lot of
different stuff
[Music]
please Jesus fix it remember she she met
him when she was 20. take the wheelchair
she says she's 24. yeah and it's been
four years yeah look at that house
that's my benefits package you're right
ma'am ma'am
it's giving welfare and nothing wrong
with that but if you're that age it's
not giving what I mean it's very true
because if I am going to be with a man
that's 70 he needs to have a captain on
the hill not that I need a mcmansion but
I'm assuming you waited this long okay
Melanie needs a mcmansion for that I'm
assuming you've waited this long because
you have built an Empire Shack in the
woods are you being nice Pearl being
nice too I'm gonna take I'm Gonna Keep
it a buck this man is I need to get a
better view of the kitchen okay Pearl
stop the camera
these two are my favorite I see some
natural ones he proposed to me we tried
for a baby three weeks later I had a
positive test and there's Lachlan
pulling my hair out now in 2019 he just
turned one at the end of January yeah I
wonder if this guy has other kids yeah
wondering too
look at all amazing he's literally the
Playhouse she must be very small and the
other thing is again I think this is
selfish do what you want obviously
they're both consenting adults however
can you imagine this kid's first I mean
people who have kids later in their 40s
are like are you the grandma I mean
that's gonna be so will he even be alive
if they have more kids she's gonna be
changing his pamper her husband's pamper
and the kids well the kids like she's
he's 70 at the kids high school
graduation if he makes it that long
he'll be 87. that's if he makes it that
long yeah he's never gonna meet a
grandkid I can't do it and she'll be
she'll be a single mother by the time
like let's say he lives to be 90 which
is pretty old he'll leave her can we can
we talk
tell their sex life that just seems so
immature and he's just like I mean he
just he's just giving me a dirty dog I
think he's just really proud to have
like gotten with her you know which fair
enough you know that's the most I mean
this is a comma I mean yeah for him and
her I don't know she just seems to have
like of a troubled past like maybe not
the best background so to her like to us
you know we're like that's the benefits
package but maybe where she's from like
that you know all she wants is she
probably just wants a stable home and to
her like a guy that takes care of her
pays the bills and gives her a child and
she can just stay and take care of the
kid you know I mean I don't think most
women really think long term if I'm
being honest like what is she still
working we just assume she's staying at
home y'all yeah I just have a feeling
um I could be wrong but how much was she
really bringing in as a bartender like
probably to her it's just like she just
wants that stability like a stripper do
you want to bringing in much if that was
her clientele
the kitchen isn't bad actually I have
lived and worse I've lived in worse
Pearl I have Pearl I'm talking about
your man is 70. y'all y'all you're close
to her age you're gonna get with a
seven-year-old and he take you back home
to that and that's your okay again I
wouldn't I wouldn't judge you I feel
like y'all are being nice and I'm just
like no ma'am this is this is bottom of
the I'm not judging if this is
somebody's circumstances get what I'm
saying but we were referring to a
benefits package right like if this is
his circumstance I'm not judging it but
I'm just keeping it like what is she
something's wrong with her I I just
think she had a trouble she just I get
the the feeling she had a really
unstable home yeah maybe this is the
first time someone's give her love and
attention like you know yeah I mean it's
gross like watching them make out them
liver spots not not with
oh get on the floor on the roof on the
whatever
goodbye dinner boy you taking that
Cialis get on that Viagra
and see what happens
uh Keel over because he's taking all
this you you know ain't no way this man
is keeping it up like that something
ain't wrong
yeah I have one boy from uh previous
marriage he would now be 24 roughly yeah
you started over you don't know how she
went to school he said he would be uh
24. so why isn't he in touch with his
son and his family he's like saying it
like he would be like he don't know
where he is or how old he actually is
something's not right we were laying in
bed one day just in the middle of that
afternoon talking Dawn tells me this
story and then I was like wait what's
his name and he repeats it I was like oh
my God like I know him you're
so-and-so's dad like I went to school
with this kid he knew my son before she
knew me and which is I didn't know a
little strange and you guys look so much
alike
you couldn't why don't you date a son
she did daddy and son didn't shared that
she was getting ran through in the
streets when she was on accident she's
Street activated
the baby is cute Donna Lachlan have an
amazing connection an amazing
relationship and watching him be a
father is so beautiful the shoe likes
the socks the cat drinks do you know
what else I didn't think about how did
they get on this TV thing all right it's
like it was probably I bet she does the
relationship she likes the attention she
gets for the age Gap what she needs to
do is clean that house this room this
house is so disorganized and a ratchet
mess ma'am look at that floor your baby
that carpet does not look it's been
clean that house look ratchet
disorganized like it's not even
decorated well like she is like what is
this yeah step up your game ma'am yeah I
think most of the women that I've seen
that have had those type of age Gap uh
relationships usually people have
something to say then when you bring
your man around they're like oh okay I
see you I see you yeah I'm not gonna say
nothing now you bring that around me and
Maggie talking about you we all ready
I'm like Maggie okay
yeah
and pearl girl
being my age I'm not worried about being
around later I mean obviously would like
to but you know Mother Nature plays a
role in it and I'm just going to take it
as far as I can after that I guess he
can push me around in my wheelchair oh
stop it I told y'all no I told you he's
looking for he's looking for nursing
care that's totally that's why I said
something's wrong with him why would you
have it I I said that from the jump
something's wrong with both of them yeah
look at her they're touching their touch
if my husband ever said yeah I'm not
worried about being around like I could
that a man does everything that he can
to be around right for his family so
that they don't have to carry that
burden but you look like Booboo the fool
with that goofy smile and she's like
yeah
but when your Nurse Betty you're not
gonna be laughing at it they're touched
they're soft in the head I'm sorry we're
trying to make them as smart as we can
he might support us financially who
knows
I am not frozen your screen was not
frozen I'm just I'm just shook you are
disgusting sir this is evil I almost
remember I said something's wrong like
this man is a uh he's a Geppetto we just
we live in such a selfish culture he's
in Japan we live in we live in such a
selfish culture where it's me me me me
me and what it's me before the family
and that's exactly what he's talking
about he's more worried about his kid
providing for him that's what you're
supposed to be worried about providing
for your kid like how many how many
times do I hear parents talk about oh
college fund oh this so that or that
like you want to set your kid up for
Success it's not a meal ticket remember
y'all told me about the benefits package
though y'all remember
first benefits pay I told you
something's wrong with this man and
something's wrong with her who says this
for him to say we're gonna make them as
smart make him as smart as we can you
can't make a child smart are you born
with the talent you have so that right
there was like you're basically trying
to load your burdens on this and you
have an adult son like right where is
that one but this is the thing boo you
ain't gonna be alive by the time he even
grows to make any money like what are
you talking the delusion is at an
all-time high in this one Alberta
Saskatchewan man Quebec that's the big
one denial there's a river in Egypt
Newfoundland Labrador I take a lot of
pictures and lachlan's gonna know that
his dad loved him and
[Music]
hi that's good are you
baby all right so I think you're gonna
you want to test drive it well yes yeah
well everyone thinks I'm a gold digger
where is the gold exactly man people see
it either where is it like Waldo this
she's asking him do you want to test
drive it I mean like why are they at the
car dealership he's like oh I guess so
like like what is wrong with him do you
think he's leading the relationship or
do you think she is oh no she has the
pants in this she just wants he seems
like a big kid there's the goal we're
looking for the goal give me the gold
babe so we're selling our Dodge girl you
can't you can be in it for a little gold
I mean I'm not saying like I'm not
saying he's got to be rich but there
could be some future you know him
looking like that but like what what
future you got he better be Daddy
Warbucks yeah looking like that now if
he's coming looking good there are some
men who are older that are fine silver
foxes yeah and I can work with it this
Melanie how old would you would you go
for I gotta see how funny is okay he
looks good how and he's still working
out and and got it together I mean like
how I can't even say it show me show me
good looking no I can't do it okay 75. I
I I don't think I can go above the 60s
like I can't I can work with Okay 60s um
the guy sent us a deposit to show that
he's serious uh last night actually
people insult me more than they insult
Dawn because I'm the gold digger I'm the
one with daddy issues I'm the one who
can't support myself I need a man to
save me I just is it true she's about to
say I'm the one who worked for leather
but cloth is fine I'm not we know
I've never worried about my age ever you
know it's just a number I thought you
were 50 when I met you
stop the cap you know honestly Nifty
she's just stroking his ego a little
like we know that's not true I think she
actually I know I'm telling you she's
soft in the mind and I don't mean that
as a disrespect for somebody who's who's
disabled when I when I'm saying solving
of my I don't mean disability what I
mean is her mind is so warped like she's
not seeing reality as what it is and
neither one of them are they're living
in illusion yeah you can tell she's
never had a real man a real man
regardless of his age protects and
provides for when he's here and for when
he's gone so a man in his 30s 40s 50s is
making sure that everything is in
preparation for his family to continue
on and the way he's talking about oh I
never think about age it's just a number
when I'm gone highly irresponsible and
clearly she doesn't keep living the same
anyway so I feel like I have a like I
have a stable relationship I
have is that a keeper yeah that's pretty
good as long as the mind is active the
body will keep following it
I don't like it
girl you don't have to worry about none
of us running up on your man be all
yours boo
well you can keep it okay you know what
I I want to say I want to say as long as
you're happy I'm happy but I'm a hater
I'm gonna be honest I'm just a hater
um I'm not happy when you're happy and
it actually grosses me out and I think
that those relationships shouldn't exist
in society so I don't have to look at
them and I think it's selfish because
you have to go around everyone has to
look at you well Pearl this is the thing
they're putting us in our in their they
want attention they want they want us to
be in their business if this was a
people walking around I mind my business
I'm not into you were on camera you
decided to call this show because you
want clout these people are probably you
know they're looking for attention like
you said and so we're allowed to judge
they want this a type of attention and
it's just like like
I don't know what like something is off
about like it's really really weird and
I don't think it's judging I think we're
using wisdom because we're hearing what
if he came out and he was really talking
about listen I I've planned this and I
have this set up for my son and and for
her because I want to make sure I've
been thinking about end of life and he
was come spouting wisdom it would I
would feel a certain way if he wasn't
talking about he's he's he's getting it
in on the floor on the roof outside side
sideways it's just they sound like she
she isn't that far from a teenager so it
makes sense but he sounds like a
teenager how you sound out Young when
you're 70.
this man is a Geppetto if you guys don't
know what a Geppetto is just take the
last part of that
yeah I decided today I'm gonna use a
shaming tactic perfect you know shame
insult guilt need to be right sometimes
I do believe in shame yeah and I believe
this we need to bring Shane back that's
why Society is the way it is yeah no no
you can't judge anybody I'm living in my
true girl bye well the truth is you
belong to the streets I'm a judger
I'm a judger me too we are they put it
out here Maggie didn't they put if they
didn't want us judging them yeah why
have they put this out here for the
street and and not only that they're so
nasty they're forcing us to look at them
kissing it's like they're it's like
voyeurism or like I don't even do that
in front of people like that I my family
or people in the street I'm just
tonguing a man down
um
yeah it was really disturbing I think
they're proud of their relationship but
I also feel like I know we talked a lot
about Society but I think Society is
going to give them or gives them I don't
want to say what they deserve but you
did hear her say you know people always
say this about me or say that about me
so they're having to defend their
relationship a lot if you have to defend
it you know there's a difference between
when single women are attacking your
relationship they're just bitter leave
them alone you know just let them let
them but when all of society is
attacking your relationship with the men
the women they all say this is weird it
might be something to think about now
I'm you know a no life experienced
person I guess so what y'all are so
sweet I've I'm like the judge I'm the
I'm the Regina George of the group from
Mean Girls right now I'm I'm the mean
girl this is disgusting you decided to
tongue it's the behavior it's a lack of
accountability the lack of planning
there's no wisdom no one's in the room
there's no adult in the room essentially
and this I blame him
um she like something's really wrong
with her but I blame him having a child
with this young woman that you know
you're not going to be around for you
certainly aren't even in the life of
your first son so like like what is
going on like but anyway anyway guys let
us know in the comments you know Art Is
Love is age just a number no matter what
the number is you know is this just
women shaming men for having their
preferences or do we have a point do we
have a point
um make sure you guys go subscribe to
both of their channels you know they got
some really great content I know
Maggie's got Wives Clubs and you know
Melanie does you know reaction videos to
crazy on the internet yeah yeah and
trying to figure out what I'm doing now
Just Go With It whatever's over there
just go with it and she was also a
really good friend of Kevin Samuels so
um a lot of his legacy lives on in her
channel so make sure you go subscribe to
that as well like the video on your way
out guys bring that notification Bell
and I'll talk to you next time